well good evening i want to start
tonight with an image that i can't get
out of my head it's this pair of green
converse sneakers a hand-drawn
heart on the right toe
they belonged to mai tai rodriguez a
nine-year-old girl who was gunned down
in the uvalde school massacre
18 other children and two teachers were
killed alongside her well last night the
actor matthew mcconaughey who was born
in novalde spoke at the white house and
gave a speech that i believe will be a
seminal moment in america's gun violence
debate
he asked his wife camilla to bring those
shoes to the briefing room
camilla's got these shoes can you show
these shoes please
wear these every day
green converse with a heart on the right
toe
this is the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about
that
i have a ten-year-old daughter she wears
sneakers she loves to draw i can't even
begin to comprehend the scale of a
horror like this nobody should it's not
normal it's not okay
and it's clear that mcconaughey can't
comprehend it either
he was visibly stung as he described
meeting a cosmetologist who worked with
the bodies of the tiny victims
this is difficult but we have to watch
it
that's the task of making the victims as
peaceful and natural as possible for
their open casket viewings
these bodies
were very different
they needed much more than makeup to be
presentable
they needed extensive restoration
why
due to the exceptionally large exit
wounds
of an ar-15 rifle
most of the bodies so mutilated
that only dna test
or green converse
could identify
[Music]
many children were left not only dead
but hollow
it's gut-wrenching isn't it and once you
have that appalling imagery in your head
there's no escaping it nor should there
be i don't think it's been a more
powerful or harrowing speech at the
white house briefing room maybe ever
and it was about so much more than just
raw emotion
mcconaughey wasn't there to take sides
or to lecture responsible gun owners to
disarm
or to preach from a lofty hollywood
platform about the ignorance of one side
or the other he didn't take sides
he even spoke about valdev in the place
where he'd learned to be a responsible
gun owner himself
now this was an appeal to all americans
whatever their views about guns
you know what
every one of these parents wanted what
they asked us for they want to make
their loss of life
matter
but we heard from we heard from so many
people right families of the deceased
mothers fathers sisters brothers texas
rangers hunters border patrol and
responsible gun owners who won't give up
their second amendment right to bear
arms and you know what they all said
we want secure and safe schools and we
want gun laws that won't make it so easy
for the bad guys to get these damn guns
i mean who wouldn't want that it's just
common sense
what matthew mcconaughey has done is
changed the tone of the gun debate from
toxic charged partisan muslim to a more
respectful rhetoric intended to unify
americans to bring about change that
could potentially save countless
innocent lives
but why has it taken an actor to do this
well he wasn't really speaking as an
actor nor was a politician he was
speaking as a father as a man from
uvalde a town whose grief has become the
world's pain and to me
his speech felt like a turning point at
least i hope it is
we got a chance right now to reach for
and to grasp a higher ground above
our political affiliations
we start
[Music]
by making
the loss of these lives
matter they have to otherwise
where are we
if you can't
make lives matter when 19 children are
gunned down at school well when can you
and if not now then when
well joining me now is fox nation host
tommy lehrer journalist and lawyer
gerardo rivera and former democrat mayor
and tv legend jerry springer welcome to
all of you three people with i guess
slightly different perspectives on all
this tommy i know your position very
pro-gun pro second amendment you've been
quite critical of mcconaughey today
herrera i know you think it was like me
a brilliant speech and you're a
conservative who says that which is
significant and jerry you and i have
discussed guns many times over the years
we've worked together uh and you're on
the democrat side of this before we get
into the debate there was a very
interesting clip i found from when i
interviewed matthew mcconaughey for good
morning britain about 18 months ago
about what he saw as the real
fundamental problem about democratic
debate right now listen to this
the extreme left and the extreme right
completely illegitimize
the other side or
they exaggerate
that that side's uh stance into an
irrational state that that makes no
sense and that's not fair when either
side does that
harald i want to start with you because
i thought he really hit the nail on the
head there that all these debates now
guns abortion whatever it is
you get the extremities on both sides
who scream the loudest
they abuse each other they mock each
other there's no consensus anymore that
the sides don't come together and reach
points of agreement and what i thought
was so striking about mcconaughey's
speech yesterday was he didn't seek to
be in cengary
he wasn't really lecturing either side
about their behavior he just wanted to
try and bring people together to try and
bring some kind of sensible move to try
and stop this kind of thing happening
i thought it appears that it was the
most brilliant heartfelt speech i had
ever heard about
gun control gun legislation responsible
gun ownership however you want to
characterize it
i think that people who
seek to belittle him as an actor or
product of hollywood
you know
brush over the fact that he was a dad
with children he is a dad with children
that is his birth town uh it was very
clear that it it ripped his heart out as
it as it should to all of us it was just
gut-wrenching uh it's it's just one of
those things appears that
i
my frustration about this is i don't
think any of it matters i don't think
that matthew mcconaughey's a speech i
don't think anyone is listening those
who are listening are already convinced
uh you know it's uh
the second amendment looms like this uh
uh you know this arbitrary uh
monstrous uh kind of edict that you must
allow even crazy people to have weapons
i i feel awful
about what happened everyone in the
united states everyone across the world
as you suggest in the uk and elsewhere
just feels that this has been a savage
savage event uh i just
despite matthew mcconaughey's eloquence
and believe me i really do believe this
is the best speech ever on this topic i
i fear nothing will happen people i mean
that's that's incredibly dispiriting to
hear that uh tommy i want to play
another clip that uh matthew mcconaughey
said this is where he he presented what
he felt were the things that needed to
be done so let's listen to this
we need to restore our family values
we need to restore
our american values
and
we need responsible gun ownership
responsible gun ownership we need
background checks
we need to raise the minimum wage to
purchase an ar-15 rifle
221.
we need a waiting period for those
rifles we need red flag laws and
consequences for those who abuse them
tell me what part of that doesn't make
complete sense and in particular in
light of what happened at avalde
well i will say i do agree with him on
restoring family values and american
values and i think a lot of this
discussion and the tragedies that have
happened in our country both in new
valley and elsewhere across our inner
cities every single weekend where we see
violence running rampant and a culture
of lawlessness i think restoring
american values family values and
changing our culture is incredibly
important and i'm glad that he mentioned
that and brought it up and i'd like to
say i do give him a lot of credit for
his speech i'm not saying that his
speech was bad i'm not saying it
offended me i'm just saying this our
constitutional rights do not come from
matthew mcconaughey any other actor any
other athlete anybody if he wants to run
for office and be elected and change our
laws and policies i would encourage him
to go for it but i will say this when we
start unraveling gun control and gun
rights there is a discussion that can be
had peers and i'm not somebody that is
so staunch in my beliefs of the second
amendment that i don't believe there's
any room for a conversation i do believe
that there are i don't believe that
there's a problem with increased
background checks however when we start
talking about red flag laws this is
where we have to really unravel this and
have a discussion because there's a lot
in the second amendment community a lot
of folks that are very worried that
someone will be able to infringe upon
our right to gun ownership based on what
he said she said saying oh this person's
crazy that person's crazy and uh seeking
a vendetta that will infringe on
someone's constitution what about the
specific point tommy what about the
specific what about this i'm not
disputing you don't raise valid points
about red flag laws it has to be run
properly but on this simple point that
he was he's three years too young this
shooter at uvalde to buy a beer
but he could buy a semi-automatic rifle
with no training
what possible logic is there that you
shouldn't just raise as mcconaughey says
the age limit as a bare minimum to 21
for kids and make it the same majors for
buying a beer
well i have to ask you this period any
time where anytime we're discussing
raising the age for things or changing
policy we need to ask is the government
really the solution here with this
person who shot his grandmother in the
face and then went on to shoot children
in a massacre would it matter if he was
18 or if he was 21 are those that have
mental illness those that seek to
destroy and kill and terrorize do they
care if they're 18. okay but tell me
okay
let me ask you this then why have any
laws
against anything if your belief is that
criminals will do it anyway
why have laws against murder armed
robbery anything i mean the whole point
of law isn't it is that you try you
you're not going to eliminate it
mcconaughey said we're not going to get
rid of the problem what you hope to do
by making further restrictions is you
reduce hopefully the level of gun
violence which as you know america isn't
just number one in the world for this
kind of thing it has more gun violence
than the next 21
wealthiest countries in the world
combined so there's clearly a problem i
think mcconaughey is just trying to work
out what can we all agree on and i just
don't think anyone i've not met anyone
in america frankly who thinks it makes
any sense that he couldn't buy a beer
for another three years but he could buy
a semi-automatic rifle i hear the
argument well he
he's old enough to be in the military
well yeah my brother was a british army
colonel just retired and you know he
when he was 18 went into the military
but he received strict training
regularly about his firearms uh
constantly updated training a civilian
doesn't need to do that they can just
wander down
uh pass a cursory background check and
buy a a military-style semi-automatic
rifle it's that that i think is crazy
jerry i want to bring you in on this
because you've always had a view about
this which i think i've i've shared uh i
accept completely by the way that as a
brit
uh it's not for me to change american
laws but do you think jerry coming from
the world of entertainment as he did now
but previously politics do you think
matthew mcconaughey and this
extraordinary speech could actually
affect change
well um
certainly it'll have some impact but the
fact is the american people
are
virtually all or pretty close to all in
agreement on the major idea of some kind
of gun control
most americans absolutely believe that
we ought to have background checks that
there ought to be red flag laws that we
in fact most americans believe that we
ought to ban assault weapons so it's not
the problem that the american people
don't want the change the problem is in
a number of issues we have a system
whereby the government doesn't
necessarily represent the will of the
voters it's a structural problem in the
government so you can have a few united
states senators
that can simply block any reasonable
legislation if you just let it up to a
vote of the american people do you think
for a second the idea of background
checks wouldn't pass do you think for a
second we wouldn't be banning assault
weapons i mean talk about an issue that
doesn't have another side
other than killing people as one thing
and two possibly because you're a
collector what in the world does anyone
outside of the military need an assault
weapon for we don't let people have hand
grenades we don't let people have rocket
launchers it has nothing to do with the
second amendment every single right in
the constitution is permitted to be
regulated if there is a legitimate
governmental purpose so for example in
the constitution we have the right
americans have the right to travel we
have the right to get on airplanes and
go places when 9 11 happened
we had regulations of that right to
travel when we got on our plane now we
have to have our
luggage inspected we have to empty our
pockets we go through metal detectors
when you have free speech which is the
first amendment there are regulations on
that yelling fire in the theater or at
four o'clock in the morning going with a
loud speaker during a residential
neighborhood and preaching your your
gospel no the police can come and say
i'm sorry you're not allowed to be be
using your microphone at four o'clock in
the morning in a residential
neighborhood we can have regulations
this is a for we can i think i think
that's absolutely yeah i think that's
absolutely correct i mean geraldo i
suppose
it seems to me this only gets resolved
if the people that matthew mcconaughey i
think he includes himself responsible
gun owners in america
reach a an agreement that they are
prepared to bring in new restrictions
without that and i think that was where
mcconaughey was very clever he didn't
try and demonize gun owners he didn't
call for any gun bans
what he said was it's incumbent on
responsible gun owners to look in the
mirror to find humility to find
knowledge to find wisdom and to find a
way through this because the world is
watching you know i remember covering
sandy hook and thinking well nothing
will be the same again as it wasn't
after 9 11 as jerry said and yet nothing
changed and here we are 10 years later
and you have almost an exact replica of
what happened at sandy hook
we do first of all i'd like to say hi to
uh mayor springer my former colleague in
the daytime talk arena jerry great to be
on the show with you tommy i see much
more often
you know piers i wish that i had a more
optimistic message i wish that as in
most of human nature what you said was
true that the consensus wants this and
therefore ultimately this will happen
this is not that situation as you
personally experience peers in your u.s
tenure
this is a lobby that is
absolutely intransigent there is no
movement whatsoever for example ever
since the parkland massacre in florida i
i had happened to have dinner with
president and mrs trump a private dinner
just the the the family it was actually
the president and his sons
laura at mar-a-lago and we the president
had just left the hospital parkland
hospital and he had seen the damage
caused by that military-style assault
weapon how it had uh evaporated entire
uh limbs and heads and uh you know
eviscerated these people how it was uh
you know he had never seen anything like
it he was he was deeply shaken and he
was moved so i proposed to him i said mr
president
nicholas cruz the shooter in this case
we're 19 years old how can it be that he
can't have a beer as you said pierce and
he can buy this weapon how can that be
that he can access that the same thing
in sandy hook with adam lanza the same
thing recently in buffalo and of course
in uvalde where you have these teenagers
that are absolutely restricted in u.s
law from alcohol consumption by driving
a truck or anything like that but yet
they can buy these weapons i propose to
the president a juvenile assault weapons
ban a juvenile assault this we can do
this we can get the age from 18 to 21
well i'm not banning anything i'm not
taking any of your assault weapons i
have this modest step logical step if
you can't drink a beer you can't buy an
assault weapon let's just do that and i
swear to god i have seen the iron doors
closed
like i said i took my blood i hope
that's not the case i mean
i just want to end this debate with just
playing one more clip this is dr roy
guerrero he was the pediatrician who
actually witnessed and had to treat some
of the young bodies
and he said this
two children whose bodies have been
pulverized by bullets fired at them
decapitated
whose flesh had been ripped apart
that the only clue at their identities
was a blood spider cartoon clothes still
clinging to them
i don't know how anyone can listen to
stuff like that about kids in classrooms
when they should be nurturing their
lives and being tall educating moving on
and not actually want to do something so
i just hope people listen to that speech
by mcconaughey listen to the testimony
today of the young kids who smeared
themselves with their friends blood in
the classrooms so that they could
pretend to be dead
listen to these people who had to treat
these bodies and then look at that pair
of sneakers and understand that the
mother of that little girl mighty
that they could only recognize that
little girl from her sneakers and if
that doesn't affect change i really
don't know what ever will
um thank you to my panel i really
appreciate it and i think i want to
carry on this debate in the spirit that
matty mcgonagall wants to do it which is
not to demonize anyone on any of the
sides here just to somehow try and
affect some change so thank you to jerry
gerardo and tommy much appreciated